bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour une nouvelle vidéo abonnés
aujourd'hui on s'intéressait à
l'ouverture ragot zine et à une petite
variante pour les blancs qui est devenu
très populaire ces derniers mois en
témoigne la partie qu'on va analyser
entre un pic au néon qui a les pièces
blanches contre où il fan c'est une
partie extraite du championnat du monde
en novembre 2011 gagné par où il fane
cette partie fut une partie clé de ce
championnat du monde
on va donc rapidement passé les quatre
premiers coups pour arriver à la
position de base de l'arago zine donc
c'est c4e six cavaliers trois cavaliers
f6 d4 d5 sur g37 une version catalane
mais les blancs vous câble et c3 et
l'arago zine c'est fou mais quatre bien
sûr on pourra jouer fawcett qui mène à
un gambit dame foulée 4 donc c'est un
kung fu qui est intéressant puisqu'on
fait pression sur le cavaly c3 et les
noirs ont pour optique de doubler les
pions après fou prend ses 3 des français
3 le coup fawcett est quant à lui
beaucoup plus solide puisque le four est
à côté du roi noir sur petit rock et il
n'y aurait pas de clouage si les blancs
venaient à mettre un fou un g5 donc
après fondé 4 on va plutôt étudier une
petite variante puisque le grand coup le
coût principal c'est fou j'ai cinq mais
je voulais dit depuis quelques mois et
bien beaucoup de 2700 et 2800 et loge où
damas quatre échecs auront alors damas
quatre échecs au roi force bien sûr la
réplique des noirs kbc 6 puisque sur
tout autre coup les blancs gagnerait une
pièce part d'un profond des 4 donc après
que la police ait 6 nous avons deux
écoles en quelque sorte
l'ancien et la moderne l'ancien c'est la
cavalière 5 c'est un coût qui avait été
jouée par tiga tigran petrossian à
l'époque cavaliers de 5,7 à coup tout à
fait logique puisque ont fait pression
sur le cavaly c6 et emmena simplement de
gagner un pion avec cavaliers prend ses
6 puis sur foot français trois échecs
des français 3 eh bien on s'aperçoit que
lecavalier 6 donc doit être repris et
l'aurait alors d'un français 6 échec au
roi qui viennent un pur net
donc après et cavaliers ou cinq on est
encore obligé de répliquer par foot
bessette puisque sur foot français trois
échecs b prend ces trois fous décès
ce serait une petite catastrophe pour
les noirs et les blancs continuerait par
cavalier prend 17 d'un pro 17
et maintenant voilà pourquoi il ne faut
pas prendre le cavalier c3 il y aurait
fou à 3 et le x 3 empêche les noirs de
voter puisque le faut attendre contrôler
la case des fuites donc après le sixième
koukava lieu le 5 les noirs en quelque
sorte sont forcés de répliquer fou 17,7
rossion à l'époque avait pris en 17 et
on en voit maintenant l'évolution de la
théorie ancien vers la théorie moderne à
l'époque les noirs avaient répliqué par
d'un pro 17 et petrossian avait pris
d'abord comme l' avantage après le coût
à 3 français 3 échecs et des princes et
rois et sur cavaliers 4 les blancs
avaient joué dame ces deux ont fait un
petit bilan sur cette position les
blancs ont des plans doublé en c3 et c2
mais vont posséder le centre et surtout
on la perd de fou qui va être très très
importante dans cette position je vais
vous donner encore quelques coups de
cette partie qui est assez connu de
petrossian sur cabaye à 5 lille et c'est
bien sûr de bloquer cette position est
de prendre le pion c4 après puis on
prenait 5 puis on prend des 5
il faut réagir de manière de manière
très agressive avec les blancs et après
trois cavaliers des 6 e 4 on s'aperçoit
que les blancs au centre avec une très
belle chaîne de pions en c3 des 4 2 4 et
f3 les fouilles vont venir en d3 et f4
on va faire petit rock et on va ensuite
attaqué les droits donc tout à l'air
bien pour les blancs le problème c'est
que je voulais dit la théorie a évolué
et après le septième coup cavale et
prend 17 et bien les noirs ont trouvé la
parade
depuis et reprennent le cavalier par le
cavalier et c'est une partie de
référence entre les polonais bartels et
le tchèque l'as nika qui s'est jouée en
2007 après cavale et prend 17 et bien
les blancs ont arrêté de jouer ce fameux
coup ci aussi aussi d'une coupe
cavaliers ou cinq et ont maintenant
opter pour 3 pourquoi après cavale et
prendrait sept tout va bien pour les
noirs tout d'un coup les décès sur trois
est bien on joue maintenant cavalier b6
et on va se débarrasser un petit peu de
toutes les pièces au centre puisqu'on
force maintenant dame b 3 il faut
protéger ce pion c4 maintenant les noirs
prennent tous pensé 4 avec pions
français quatre faux prend ses 4
cavalier français qu'adam français 4 et
maintenant d'amener 5 on voit l'idée de
cette manoeuvre qui a validé cette
cavale et b6 la dame des cinq attaques
la dame sekkat attaque le plonger de
puisqu'il n'y a plus de fous en f1 et
sur dame prend des cinq petits coups
intermédiaire fou prend ses trois échecs
des princes et rois puis on prend des 5
nous sommes au 13e coup nous n'avons
plus que deux tours cavaliers pour les
noirs contre deux tours fou pour les
blancs et on s'aperçoit que le fou de
casement est enfermé derrière sa propre
chaîne de pions f 2 3 et des 4 alors que
le cavalier on sait si c'est lui à des
superbes case et le cavalier peut venir
en a cinq essais 4 ensuite on contrôle
simplement la case de 4 paresse et f5 et
les noirs ont un bon avantage
positionnelle dans cette partie barthel
a réussi à faire nul mais donc après
cette partie qui s'est jouée en 2007 et
bien on a arrêté de jouer cavalier e 5
voilà et bien un petit peu l'historique
de cette variante
voilà pourquoi aussi mme cooke o nayrou
a opté pour que troy qui est un coût
beaucoup plus solide alors même si le
fou de cases noires restent enfermés il
va pouvoir se développer sur la case et
2 et sur la future diagonale à 3 et
fuite
donc après un e3 ou dit fan a joué petit
rock et surfe ou des deux eh bien nous
n'attendons pas que le fouet fin soit
développée pour gagner un tempo on prend
directement et ont fait puis on prend
ces quatre fous prend sa carte à fond de
6 voilà l'idée je dirais hypermoderne de
cette variante avec ta main cas d'échec
les noirs jouent pouvait théâtre suivie
de food et 6 quelle est l'idée étrange
avoir mis un cavalier ans et si c'est un
fou on essayait c'est bien maintenant
les noirs veulent se libérer par le 6e 5
et on va dire c'est ce qui a changé
c'est ce qui a changé puisque d'habitude
dans ce genre de position on avait
plutôt l'habitude de voir les noirs se
développer avec un cavalier en 17 pour
jouer ensuite c'est cette c5 puis b 6
puis fou bessette maintenant les noirs
préfère mettre un cavalier en c6 est un
fou et indécise pour une autre poussée
libératrice qui est de 6 e 5
les blancs donc doivent recycler la
gamme a4 qui n'a rien à faire sur cette
case et joue de manière très solide dame
c2 qui également anticipe une future
menace avec a6b 5 à 6 c
des jouets maintenant aux menaces b5
suivi d'un bêta très rapide il faut donc
eh bien je crois le coup prophylactique
c'est ce que va faire connaître ou en
jouant le coup à trois puisque sur
maintenant b5 il y aurait fumé 3 et sur
bekaert on pourrait simplement prendre
le pion par apprend mais 4 après le
dixième qu à trois les noirs continuent
leurs plans de manière très logique avec
eux 5 et comment réagir dans cette
position pour les blancs et bien on joue
puis en province cinq cavaliers prend
1,5
carval éprouvait 5-fu prend 1,5 et f4
alors c'est vraiment une approche je
dirais très moderne de 7,2 cette
variante et on va je pense l'avoir
évoluer dans l'est dans les mois qui
arrivent
puisque f4 ce n'est pas un coup très
joli en effet le pion aux 3 est
maintenant arriérés et on se dit qu'avec
une tour en 8es bien on pourrait faire
faire pression sur sur ce pion assez
facilement
cependant les blancs gagne à la paire de
fou puisque si les noirs ici joue food
et 6 c'est bien l'idée de connerie
reconnaît roux aura été de jouer de 3,4
on s'aperçoit qu'on a simplement de 4,5
et les blancs refaire grand roque donc
voilà un traitement hypermoderne de
cette variante avec ce 13e kf4 les loirs
donc après il fout des six ont un
problème
voilà pourquoi winnie fans a préféré se
débarrasser de ce fou un jean [ __ ] en
c3 et surtout prend ses 3 il y as dame
e7 qui donc attaque le pion à 3 et
surtout qui vise à bloquer tout le jeu
sur cases blanches par cavaillé leucate
suivi de fou et 5 donc très bonne
réaction de la part de la joueuse
chinoise qui pose une question concrète
sur le traitement de l'ouverture de
l'indienne danse est dans cette position
est bien connue où elle a préparé cette
secoue cette variante et joue petit rock
qui sacrifie le client est roi
le challenge est relevé par la joueuse
chinoise avec d'impro ou trois échecs
roi achats et d'un v6 on ne va pas
s'attarder sur la partie puisque après
avec 4 f 5
la position est très compliqué les
joueuses auraient pu jouer de manière un
peu plus précise des deux côtés mais on
a retenu le plan des blancs c'est à dire
eh bien maintenant jouer de manière plus
souple avec eux 2 3 pour essayer de
gagner la paire de fou et
rapidement contré le plan des noirs au 6
e 5 par une rapide poussé f4 et e4 je
vous invite donc à regarder une autre
vidéo sur un aragon zing on va cette
fois traité un autre coup kodama cas
d'échec on regardera le coût principal
fou j'ai cinq dans quelques jours à très
bientôt
on